bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got ethan
here with me thank you so much for doing
this
hey thanks a lot for having me on for
sure let's just start with uh with your
background
uh you're in toronto now but where'd you
grow up and what did you do before
you started building in the crypto space
sure uh so i'm in toronto born and
raised in toronto
um i spent most of my university life at
the university of guelph is about an
hour away from toronto
um see my academic background has really
been
motivated by uh four kind of main big
questions that have occupied me
successfully over the years and those
are you know what does it mean to be
human
what does it mean to be alive uh what
does it mean to agree
and what does it mean for something to
be money and those later two sort of
overlapped with
with getting involved in
cryptocurrencies and you know i've been
in that space for
almost eight years now i guess um but
most of it most of my time was really
preoccupied with the sort of what does
it mean to be a live question and so i
usually say my background was in
biophysics i studied the sort of
biophysical origin of life and this
problem of how is it
in a world that's allegedly always
running down according to the second law
of thermodynamics and the sort of
everyday experience of you know entropy
increasing
how is it in such a world that organisms
living systems manage to run themselves
up that we have these sort of
amazing emergent phenomena um
and it sort of came to understand living
systems as
fundamentally sustainable systems uh as
systems that preserve themselves over
time in
really interesting biophysical ways um
and that
you know led me to really think about
you know how we could use technology
and build technological systems to
resemble more these sort of sustainable
organic biological systems than the sort
of you know hurricanes or tornadoes that
we're so used to building especially
in uh in the financial world and so
sometime in my early 20s i was turned on
to say austrian economics and and the
sort of how the financial system works
and rallying against the federal reserve
and
all that kind of good stuff um and and
shortly thereafter found my way to
bitcoin
um and then the rest is kind of history
so when you found bitcoin what kind of
caught your attention was it the
austrian
kind of philosophy just embodied in a
product or what was that initial thing
that just
yanked you down the rabbit hole yeah i
mean uh it took me a bit of time to
really grock it i had seen it a few
times but it was really only in 2013
around uh when that whole cypress crisis
happened
that it really really took me by storm
that like here was something
uh not only that seemed to be an answer
to the sort of austrian economic
tradition but that also you know really
appealed to my biophysical background
because it felt like this was
the emergence of life in the sort of
biophysical or sorry in the digital
medium so what i've been studying the
biophysical medium now happening
in this digital reality where you have
this like self-emergent
um kind of you know sustaining uh entity
um and that seemed really interesting
and important
and it was in the summer of of 2013 that
i actually programmed my first bitcoin
transaction from scratch
uh in python which was sort of a
profound experience to be able to have
you know a financial or economic system
that's so open that a programmer
you know in their own bedroom with no
permission or you know talking to anyone
can basically program a
transaction that can carry an arbitrary
amount of value from scratch and so from
there i was
i was just really hooked um there's no
turning back yeah
absolutely and so when you kind of go
down that rabbit hole
uh you have to spend much time on
bitcoin but you end up building
different technology uh walk through
kind of that transition
or kind of why you thought that bitcoin
alone wasn't uh
kind of the entire ecosystem or kind of
the entire uh
addressable uh technology base sure so
um in 2014 you know i was in toronto
ethereum was invented in toronto
and so we started going to the the
ethereum meetups here
um and and you know really kind of were
taken with this idea of
fully programmable um money not just
programmable money but arbitrary
computation and sort of world computer
vision
um and that seemed it didn't seem like
fully the end of the story but it
definitely seemed like the next step and
so we got you know really involved in
the early ethereum community
um i i joined the company in 2014 that
was
trying to take the i think the first
company that was trying to actually
commercialize ethereum
for enterprise uh and obviously in 2014
it was still way too early but that
company is monax industries
they're still around today um and in in
late 2014
uh me and a number of others started
really thinking about okay what happens
next
it seems there's going to be you know
not just this ethereum blockchain but
there's going to be a proliferation of
blockchains they can't all use
um proof of work and so you know
at that time there had been a lot of
discussion around uh around this sort of
proof of stake idea this idea that you
could actually use
your stake in the system um to secure
the system rather than some external
external work and so you know there was
a night actually in
in 2014 where vlad zambia and i spent
the whole night up
um you know talking about about proof of
stake and brainstorming what all this
was going to look like and i was going
to really convince
ourselves that that proof of stake was
the future and that in this world in
this proliferation of blockchains
um you know proof of stake was going to
play a big role in that and you know
both of us have pretty much been
committed to
uh to bringing proof of stake about ever
since and all that time i sort of
reserved my you know i've always
considered myself like a closet bitcoin
maximalist because even though i've been
sort of
you know devoted to proof of stake for
like you know six years now or something
um i've still never never kind of
dropped this love or appreciation for
bitcoin and i think it has a very
important role
um in the long term but a lot of the
next few years for me were really about
uh starting to bring proof of stake to
light initially through tendermint and
then through the sort of larger idea of
cosmos and
how the many different proof of state
blockchains would be able to uh to
connect to one another and not just
exist alone but actually in sort of an
interoperable web like
the internet got it so walk us through
kind of cosmos and what you're building
yeah so the idea with cosmos uh we call
it an internet of blockchains but it
really follows what does that mean
what does internet of blockchains mean
so let me explain it in terms of
an analogy to the internet right so you
know when you think about the internet
where the internet came from once upon a
time there were people before the
internet there were computers
you know and there was sort of this idea
of you know there might just be a single
mainframe
a really large computer that would be
able to handle like all of the world's
computing right maybe ibm or some other
large company was like we got it we're
going to build the world's computer
right uh and obviously that's not the
way things panned out it didn't make
sense for a million reasons
doesn't have the kind of customizability
the scale the sort of sovereignty that
individual
users want out of computing devices and
now we live in a world where there's
more devices than there are human beings
you have computing devices in your
pocket
you have complete control over your
device but they're all interoperable
with one another they can all
connect to each other over standard
protocols of the internet and so the
idea behind the internet of blockchains
is something very similar
each blockchain is itself like a
computer you can think of it like a like
a device
or a machine and there isn't going to be
just one right there is this sort of
world computer vision that ethereum has
like oh all of the world's computing
needs can happen on the ethereum
blockchain
it's very similar to trying to say all
the world's good computing needs to
happen on a single ibm
mainframe we don't believe that's true
um you know it didn't turn out to be
true
and so the idea with the internet of
blockchains and with cosmos
is to really enable that proliferation
of blockchains for there to be thousands
millions of them for each community
maybe not each individual but but for
each community or
each city or you know each company or
whatever
to be able to build their own blockchain
to represent their own values so they
sort of have this
um sovereignty over these networks uh
control over the networks and where
they're going and yet for those
different blockchain networks to still
be interoperable with one another in the
same way that
you know i have sovereign control over
over my laptop here but it's
interoperable with yours and and we're
able to communicate with each other over
the internet and so
that same vision we've been trying to
bring that to the blockchain world as
there's going to be this proliferation
of blockchains many of them are still
sort of siloed and not really talking to
each other they're just starting to talk
to each other using
you know bespoke ad hoc protocols and
what we're really trying to do
is define standards like tcp defined for
the internet
to enable arbitrary machines arbitrary
blockchains to communicate
arbitrary information uh in a secure
manner between themselves and and that's
really what caused us about those values
of
sovereignty and interoperability
enabling any community to have a
blockchain
that is sort of there that's true to
their values but still be interoperable
with all the other blockchains in the
world
got it and so when you think through
this interoperability
um explain like how does this world work
from like a user experience standpoint
is it something where i'm using a
product i don't even understand what
blockchains
are kind of running underneath it's more
like the internet protocols i don't
really understand what internet
protocols are working i don't even know
the names of some of them but like i
know if i go to google.com i can
access this massive database and get an
answer to any of my questions
um is that kind of how you see the
blockchains all uh kind of working
together
but it's it's kind of behind the scenes
it's uh
really kind of pushed away from the user
and therefore the technical community
will understand it but actually the end
users don't see any of this stuff
yeah possibly i mean i mean that's one
route um and i think that's
uh that's not unlikely and and is a
perfectly valid vision
on the other hand i have a little bit of
um hankering for this idea that
users should actually not be agnostic to
the to their infrastructure
and that a big part of the problems in
society today are how much we've
abstracted away
the underlying infrastructure or say
supply chains that support
any given product or user experience and
so i think it's actually important to
surface more of
you know what you're using and how it's
brought to you
to individual users and there's
obviously a challenge in that in in what
that ux looks like
today i mean a lot of people are sort of
building towards that world where
you know you don't have to worry about
what blockchain you're on and the user
is sort of you know not aware of it and
so maybe it functions a lot like the
internet but
you know that's a dangerous road if the
blockchain world goes the same route
that the internet
went in terms of being dominated by a
very small number of very large
you know multinational corporations um i
don't think that's a world any of us are
really
really trying to bring about and um you
know we don't talk about that too much
we sort of just wave our hands and say
you know oh decentralization and it's
all going to be great
um but but no i think we really do have
to have to worry about that sort of
the relationship between applications
and infrastructure and exposing more
of the infrastructure through the
application so that the user has more
awareness of
uh you know more awareness and more
participation in the actual
uh hosting of these networks and i think
we're not quite there yet because
even you know even as we decentralize
all these applications the backbone of
the internet itself is still very
uh centralized through isps but there is
some work ongoing and in meshnets and
even some
projects built on cosmos that are
actually really trying to decentralize
the underlying infrastructure of the
internet itself and have the users
actually more involved
in providing that so i think that i
think we really need to close the loop
on
uh users being aware of that of that
infrastructure but there's a sort of
long road ahead to get that in the short
term probably yes the ux will be very
much you don't know what you're using
and it doesn't matter absolutely um i
know that when you think through this
um there's kind of you know thousands if
not millions of blockchains in uh your
perspective
how does that work from uh kind of a
technical
uh point of view is this something where
uh it's kind of like an
amazon aws server where you can
literally go in you can spin one up and
you can use it to host your own website
and so
there's some kind of ability to like
spin up a blockchain for your specific
use case
um is it no there's really thousands of
teams that build their own for their own
purposes like how do you just use
getting from where we are today where i
would say
you know there's a ton of different um
you know cryptocurrency or
uh altcoins etc but really there's only
maybe
10 to 15 blockchains they're actually in
use in any real size or meaningful
adoption
how do we get from that point to uh this
world that you believe where there's you
know millions and millions of
blockchains
yeah so the question is sort of who runs
who runs these blockchains how are they
operated and how is it not just
you know bezos or basis computers um and
that's a really good question and that
takes a lot of time
and cosmos has sort of pioneered um you
know bringing proof of stake networks to
life
and really focusing on building up the
confidence the competence of the
validator sets the actual
uh operating nodes node operators that
run these things and so we've spent a
lot of time
sort of over the last few years
nurturing the validator
community and now just like bitcoin
mining became a business model and now
there's a bunch of bitcoin miners
there's a growing number of
proof-of-stake validator
businesses right entire businesses who
dedicate themselves to
highly secure highly available operation
of these networks and so
that as sort of a business sector um is
growing and it's sort of one of the
you know i think we wanted one of the
legacies of what you know cosmos has
really helped bring about
um and as the number of competent
validators grows from currently maybe
there's
100 or a few hundred to down the road
there will be thousands currently you
know they tend to be
somewhat larger businesses but maybe
eventually there will be more
um smaller or household businesses or
hobbyists that are able to participate
more actively
uh in these networks depending on the
actual security requirements
so right now when you know a lot of
people argue that uh argue this is like
a critique against cosmos that like oh
if i want to build an application on
cosmos
it's not like ethereum where i just like
write a smart contract deploy it and
forget about it the miners will run it
and cosmos you have to go and actually
like recruit a validator set and
convince them with a new token or
whatever that it's
that's worth it to run your network um
that's true today and we think that's
actually really important like i was
saying that
you understand who's running you know uh
your infrastructure and that they're
involved and participating
but we're also working on on uh tools
and services
um that will make it a lot easier to
actually recruit validators in a more
automated way setting up marketplaces
and actually leverage um existing
validator sets for instance for the
cosmos hub where the
where the atom token resides um to
leverage those validators and their
staked
atoms on the cosmic subchain to actually
validate and secure
other chains while today it may be
difficult you have to go recruit a
validator set uh it's only going to get
easier as more validators
more competent validators come online
and as we build tools and services to
make it easy to spin up blockchains
there's also a number of products
there's uh so starport is a tool being
built in the cosmos ecosystem that makes
it really easy to just
spin up a chain even if the nodes are
running on aws or whatever and
progressively move it to a more
sort of independent validator set a lot
of what uh your viewpoint of the world
is is driven by the philosophy of cosmos
and and uh
you and the other people working on this
maybe talk through a little bit of that
philosophy
um and why you're so adamant about uh
you know kind of defining the philosophy
and then constantly
checking to make sure that you're you're
kind of always working within the
boundaries of it
yeah i mean so you know a lot of people
think technologies are
uh neutral uh in a way i mean they're
not they're they're typically driven by
it by the values of the founders and
it's really
important to um you know to stay true to
those values and we see things like you
know google
initially founded with like don't be
evil uh and now i don't know they change
their model to something stupid but it's
no longer don't be evil
uh you know a lot of other people in
crypto talk about this like can't be
evil philosophy
which is really great because you like
program thing to not be evil um
there there's a lot in the world the
sort of political economics and i think
the blockchain space has really blown
open the doors on what we can do
with political economics but
fundamentally like the problems in our
time
are political economic problems where
you know there's the institutions are
losing a lot of legitimacy
um you know the nation states have kind
of gotten too big to effectively manage
themselves they're too complex and sort
of like a hayekian sense they can't
process enough of the sort of low level
localized
information and so you know you can
think of a lot of the the blockchain
systems today as potentially making
similar kinds of mistakes
establishing themselves as like
overextended empires that are sort of
trying to dominate the whole world and
get everyone to use their system
and kind of monopolize and and we really
wanted to push back a bit against that
and say look the
most important thing is this sort of
localist bottom-up ideal right that
that individual communities can sort of
uh you know take control of their own
destinies
and their own sort of infrastructure and
use infrastructure that reflects their
own values and i don't know what their
values are right i can't say to them
use this thing because this thing is
correct and i'm gonna i'm gonna force it
on you and whatever
the important thing is to you know give
them technologies that allow them
to reflect their own values whether i
agree with them or not right
and that was really what drove what
drove cosmos was this idea of
sovereignty that
you know any community um could do this
could could put together their own
blockchain to reflect their own values
whatever they might be
and still be interoperable with everyone
else so even though you have your own
value system
you're not siloed off from others you're
still interoperable and so from that
bottom-up perspective
then build you know uh global or
international
systems that connect different values um
and
different nation states and so on so
while a lot of uh you know a lot of
blockchain systems today might sort of
position themselves as these kind of
domineering empires
you could think of the cosmos model as
more like the nation state right it's
like
each country sort of fragments out of
these empires
they have their own constitution their
own citizenry their own culture and
value system
and yet they're still kind of
interoperable with all the others and so
that
that balance of sovereignty and
interoperability we think is really
important
not just to the blockchain space but
also uh to political economics writ
large right and there's sort of the
you know history of the last few
thousand years as this kind of
you know this tension between
sovereignty and hegemony or between
isolation and interconnection right and
really trying to
surface that historical political
economic trend and
and its importance today like if you
look at you know municipalities still
don't have
really constitutional recognition or
legitimacy they're still kind of agents
of the state
where more than 50 of the population now
lives in cities and you know we have a
lot of problems because
the lack of say independent monetary
policy by cities or so on right so
um the goal cosmos is really to sort of
bring that philosophy to light and
and remind people that yes uh you know
we do have sort of control over our
destinies or at least we should
and we can build technology that really
enables that and that's really what we
what we have been prioritizing and you
know we think to great success as we now
see
uh arguably causing the most successful
blockchain application platform
after ethereum you know ethereum came
first and sort of had this first mover
advantage but people have really
gravitated towards this sort of software
and ideal that oh i can use this tech
and i don't have to
subscribe to some other person's
political economic ideals because i can
i can assert my own right
um yeah absolutely and so when you think
through this you keep mentioning
localism um describe like what exactly
you mean by that and why is that kind of
a key focus for you
you talked a little bit about the
municipalities but like just kind of go
deeper on that
yeah so you know i think the world is
unfathomably complex
like uh so complicated right yeah
um and so the idea that that we're gonna
build
um states uh and governments
that are gonna have purview over these
increasingly complex geopolitical
domains
um i think it's really arrogant and uh
and we could do with a little bit more
humility and
not not just that but the there's so
much diversity in the sort of
constituency
of these um you know geopolitical
domains that it's really not possible
for a single government with the kind
you know a single like federal
government say
uh with the kinds of democratic uh
mechanisms we have today to
adequately or accurately represent that
citizenry
um across the you know complete set of
ideas and issues that that matter to
them right
and so for that reason you know from a
sort of purely like physical
information theoretic foundation um
it seems to me that we very much need to
move to a more a more localist
um you know political economics and
governing mechanisms
and also from a sustainability
perspective because if you make a
decision at such a large geopolitical
scale and you're wrong
uh the implication of that or the impact
of that is across a huge
body of people right um and so it's very
hard to tinker
right and tinkering in this sort of like
ability to have a kind of convex upside
and low downside right
where you can mess around and if you
screw up it's not a big deal but if you
find something new
you know it's a great deal you can't
really do that at a federal level or you
know when you're dealing with such a
large
um geopolitical body and so i think it's
actually really important for our
ability to sustain ourselves as a
species and a civilization
to have much more decentralized
making but you know that's not to say
that like every every decision has to be
voted on by like a large body of people
but that the locus of decision making
should be much more local and so
that the municipalities and smaller
communities shouldn't be forced to be
subject to say a nation state that's you
know sitting far away
and and is uh you know trying to decide
over a world that is way too complex for
it to process
and by the time it processes the
information you know it's already stale
right and people were raising the alarm
about this you know hayak especially in
others
over the course of the 20th century and
things have only gotten exponentially
more
more complex um since then and so it
seems really important from both
you know in order to make good decisions
and in order to be sustainable and to
preserve that ability to tinker
that we need to reduce the scope of a
lot of the geopolitical decision making
and be able to operate at say a more
municipal or even provincial level when
you do that
what happens to the let's say national
or international stage does that weaken
uh some of those other kind of
apparatuses or
does it simply just strengthen the
localism and everything else stays the
same
kind of at a national or international
level yeah i mean i don't i don't think
we know exactly
what that looks like um i think there
are ways to
continue to strengthen international
ties and and
the there's a role for a nation state
right this isn't to say let's abolish
the nation state and have like
you know anarcho-libertarianism
everywhere like no i'm not a fan of that
i'm a fan of uh very strong political
institutions
but those institutions i believe should
be much more local and should be much
more responsive
and participatory right and and like i'm
saying there's no way to do that
at a national level but i would like to
see um sort of national political
institutions
that are more clearly built up out of
the
uh the sort of subsidiary uh you know
municipal
institutions let's say rather than being
appointed or you know delegated by the
federal institution actually have the
federal institution be a reflection
of these sort of underlying processes so
we can have a bit more of a bottom-up
process for developing our national
politics and thus and then our
international relations
um you know i don't know exactly what
this is going to look like and i'm no
you know expert on on
political science or even economics uh
by any degree this is just sort of my
you know biophysical intuition my
understanding of information theory and
so on trying to
um trying to uh you know apply itself to
the political economic domain
um but i don't think we know exactly
what it's gonna look like and anyone who
pretends to you know is probably
probably wrong so one of the things
that's fascinating to me
um is the site of interoperability and
uh it feels like um everyone is arriving
at the same conclusion which is that
there's tons of experimentation
there's tons of innovation um and
progress being made across all these
different ecosystems if you strip away
the tribalism and kind of the religious
zealot
aspect of each one of these communities
and you look and say wow there is a lot
of innovation that's occurring
kind of on a totality basis wouldn't it
be awesome if a user or a developer or a
product
could leverage all of that different
innovation that would probably be pretty
powerful and so this is where kind of
the idea of interoperability comes in
how exactly do you see where we are
today so forget kind of the promise of
it and forget kind of the things that
haven't worked but when you look today
if we just took a snapshot like
how interoperable are certain products
are the teams with each other trying to
build like just where are we today as a
kind of a check-in or a state of the
union for interoperability if you will
yeah so i mean so ethereum from the
beginning has had this this
uh feature of interoperability people
refer to as composability you build a
smart contract on ethereum
it can atomically communicate with every
other contract on ethereum and that has
you know exploded in the form of d5
today and all the sort of
uh power of this sort of you know
financial legos um that people are
building
what's happening with all the other
blockchains is that their first order of
business is to build a bridge to
ethereum right
and so every one of them is sort of you
know approaching interoperability by
first
building a bespoke or sort of ad hoc
bridge to ethereum to allow them
and their functionality uh to
interoperate with what's happening on
ethereum and extend the sort of
you know domain of composability on
ethereum onto the other chains
one of the challenges is is that across
those bridges
the sort of raw atomic composability of
ethereum
doesn't extend cleanly right and so a
lot of people now are trying to
understand
what that what that looks like to
actually you know have these
uh these sort of defy legos um on
different blockchains with a bridge in
between
like an asynchronous bridge in between
um and what that means
for composability in that world so i
think we're at the you know we're sort
of at the beginning of trying to
understand composability
in this world of many blockchains where
not everything is on in a single state
machine
the other thing that's starting to
happen and i think that that cosmos is
really driving this
is the idea of standardized
interoperability protocols and so ours
is we call it ibc the inter-blocking
communication protocol
um you may you may know that it's
actually planned to launch in about
12 hours we're doing a major upgrade to
the cosmos hub which will see
the ibc protocol they'll be working on
for a long time finally go live
and the idea with ibc is to really
standardize in much the same way that
tcp
standardized communication over the
internet to standardize communication
between blockchain so that
every bridge and every interoperable set
of blockchains isn't just built in sort
of a bespoke ad hoc way but that we
really have like
clean extensible well understood
standards that we can then build on top
of right so ibc is not just
a low-level protocol it's also sort of
an extensible platform that people can
build extensions on and we can start to
understand maybe more formally
what composability is going to look like
across these different blockchains
got it and so when you think through
this uh the name was what standardized
uh what was the ibc stand for uh
inter-blockchain communication
inter-blockchain communication and so
the communication part i think is
what's so fascinating here of just
that's ultimately what is happening and
so if you again take with tribalism you
look at hey just the ability for these
things to work together
ends up being kind of a one plus one
equals like three or four rather than
two how do you see um us moving forward
and where are the biggest
obstacles is it a human problem or is it
a technical problem by human i mean
is it literally just like we're all
idiots and everyone's just staring at
each other being like now we don't want
to work together
or is there actually very identifiable
technical challenges that still lay
ahead that people need to solve in order
for this to work on kind of a global
skill across a bunch of these different
uh open protocols yeah so i think it's
mo
it's funny because it's mostly a
communication problem right uh
so a lot of the humans are actually
working very closely together and we're
seeing a lot of
a lot of the different projects sort of
put the tribalism aside and figure out
how to build bridges to each other so
we're all stronger if we all
we all connect together and that's
that's probably true but i say it's
mostly a communication problem because
a lot of people are still speaking
different languages or they're using you
know
different academic backgrounds or
they're using language that is sort of
informally defined and so
i think there's a real challenge right
now actually formalizing the guarantees
that we get the sort of security
security guarantees that we get out of
interoperability and trying to
understand
the different failure modes right and
you know d5 sort of has this
has this problem with which is that it's
as much as it's transparent on ethereum
you can see everything that's happening
it's still very complex and to trace the
routes through
you know to through a sequence of
transactions even if they're all
happening
atomically you know it's it's led to all
these kind of um you know some people
might call them hacks but they're
they're more like uh arbitrage
opportunities massive arbitrage
opportunities
that derive from this kind of
composability on ethereum right where
you take out a flash loan over here and
you end up being able to
you know take out a huge amount of money
out of some other contract and then pay
back your loan
um because this sort of you know
cross-chain communication
is just getting started and there are a
number of ways to do it and a number of
different ways these bridges are secured
i don't think we have a really strong
understanding across all the different
humans across all the different teams
of exactly what kinds of security
guarantees we get and how to think about
them and how to formalize them and build
applications on top of them and then how
to surface those guarantees to users
both to developers and to end users who
want to know
you know when i put up um some funds
over here what are the sort of terms or
what are the guarantees i get out of
that
right um and a lot of that people will
probably try to gloss over with
insurance and other things sort of like
what's happened
in the traditional financial system but
i think we have an opportunity to really
really drill down and try to formalize
our communication and
and uh the models of interoperability
here and that's
a lot of what um we've been trying to do
with ibc is to really formalize the
standard so people can understand
exactly what kind of guarantees they're
getting
and therefore how to use it um can you
give us a
um example of something that is not
possible without interoperability and so
when you have interoperability it then
either one becomes possible or two it's
a
such a significant inflection point that
it becomes valuable whereas without the
interoperability it's not very valuable
yeah i mean one of the one of the
simplest things is just trading across
uh across chains right so um
you can imagine right now on ethereum if
everything's built on ethereum um it's
great you have unit swap and you have
other decentralized exchanges there and
you can all
they can all trade uh against each other
on youtube but if you have coins on
many different other chains and you know
you wanna you wanna have some price
discovery mechanism between them
right now the only option is basically
to send everything off the blockchain to
some centralized exchange
now you have a lot more custody risk you
have regulatory risk um you have all
these other
all these other issues and and the
platform is no longer extensible you
can't build around right
and so one of the sort of you know
initial holy grails let's say of
interoperability
is uh being able to have exchange across
many more platforms without having to
trust some centralized third party
and incurring all that all that
customers but that's a very you know
first
order sort of thing um another sort of
major
thing you get out of interoperability uh
which is sort of one of the again the
driving features of cosmos and this idea
of sort of
sovereignty is also fault isolation
right so
on ethereum if you if you build up you
know this huge set
of of contracts and they're all talking
to each other or whatever
a bug in any one of them can affect sort
of all of them right because they're all
kind of composed together
uh in a more uh in the sort of
interoperability model that we've been
pushing for
in cosmos where every chain is sort of
independent but it's still able to
communicate
if one of those chains fails for
whatever reason it doesn't necessarily
affect
all the other chains that are sort of
connected up right you can you can
isolate those faults and so
it gives us a more uh kind of rigorous
and fault-tolerant way to actually build
up
these systems and so that's not to say
that you know necessarily that's a
feature that wasn't possible without it
but you know having better fault
tolerance is sort of the whole point of
blockchains in the first place right
it's
sort of like the classic argument what
can you do with a blockchain that you
can't do without
and people say oh you get fault
tolerance and censorship resistance and
all these sort of things
um you know so uh you can make a similar
argument for sort of the
interoperability we're pushing for
that you get that sort of fault
isolation you can experiment more
you don't have to upgrade a single
blockchain to get new features you can
launch another one
and so on so it allows a lot more uh
experimentation
and even more permissionless innovation
let's say without putting others
at risk absolutely let's talk about
proof of stake before
we go into the rapid fire questions to
finish up uh proof of stake proof of
work there's two very very different
camps
of thought there what is your argument
as to why proof of stake
is necessary and then what do you think
the advantages of proof of stake are
over proof of work in your opinion
so um i believe there should be one or a
very small number of proof-of-work
blockchains
i think proof-of-work provides something
to the world that we don't otherwise
know how to achieve and that's this sort
of thermodynamic immutability
which is to say uh you know a record a
legible record
um that the the security of which the
mutability of which is guaranteed by
thermodynamics
that's very powerful especially in a
highly uncertain geopolitical situation
like we're in today and are likely to
continue to be in for the next you know
century if not more
um so that's really important but that
said it is
uh a huge huge energy cost
right and so if we are going to have a
proliferation of blockchains which we
will because
blockchains themselves are just the sort
of next evolution of you know the
automation of uh digital
digitization of human processes and so
on uh we can't have them all run on
proof of work so we need
an alternative right and proof of stake
has really emerged as the most viable
uh leading alternative to proof of work
but proof of stake isn't isn't the end
either right i think we're sort of
we're gonna see a sort of natural
progression from the sort of global
anonymous proof of work systems towards
more
local and identifiable um uh
you know security systems right and so
proof of stake is a step towards that
then you might go from
uh you might step from proof of stake to
something like proof of bandwidth where
now
you know the participation in the
network is is determined by how much
bandwidth you're actually providing and
then we can actually think about
you know um individuals and communities
providing their own
uh internet infrastructure and then you
know i would hope we would go to
something even more
local and real like uh proof of produce
or proof of care
or whatever right where the actual um
you know security
or core infrastructure is provided by
say the farmers and people who are
actually providing
um you know the means to keep us alive
right so i think
there's gonna be this gradual
progression you know proof of work was
necessary to get the thing started but
there'll be this gradual progression
from this sort of global
anonymous group of work world to
something much more local into building
systems that are based on
more local work or more local kinds of
activity
got it and so when you think through it
if there's one kind of proof of work
system
that uh is kind of the dominant one
there in the proof of stake side is that
also true where there's just one or is
this kind of the idea of no
everybody else needs to be proof of
stake and therefore that's where you get
interoperability and
kind of a lot of things we talked about
today yeah there's gonna there's gonna
be many right now i mean if you're
launching a new blockchain the best way
to do it is to use
uh a group of stake model and that's
sort of one of the one of the things you
know cosmos has democratized was
actually making it really easy to set up
your own group of stake chains or all
the modules and everything you need for
that is built for you
um so but you know progressively i hope
we move
even away from just this sort of raw
proof of stake based on your economic
stake
to actually other forms of more local
work um
like i was saying group of bandwidth or
you know proof of agriculture or
whatever it might be
um and we don't know exactly what that
looked like yet people are starting to
experiment with it
but i think that will sort of be the the
next evolution we'll have this sort of
hierarchy just like there's a hierarchy
of money and a hierarchy
of financial institutions there'll be
this kind of hierarchy of
infrastructure security we could call it
absolutely
what's the one thing that no one's
talking about when it comes to
proof-of-stake interoperability or the
sovereignty that you think everyone
should be paying attention to so kind of
the the most underrated aspect of
all this work that you're doing um
yeah i think it's this uh
money is the killer app you know
everyone's looking for the killer app
right now and they think it's defy and
all this kind of finance stuff
and maybe today d5 is having its moment
but i think ultimately
what's important about all this stuff is
uh democratizing the institutions of
money
and making money a much more local
phenomenon and and that's really what
i'm in it for
and what we're working towards um and
enabling you know smaller much more
local communities or
municipalities to take control over
their own
monetary policy in a way that's not say
combative with with the central banks or
the nation states
but is is actually supportive of it um
and and to get that kind of
sustainability we're in it for um from
more
localist monetary policy and so you know
a lot of people think we're just oh
we're just democratizing wall street
i think that's a great first step
important first step but the end goal is
really
sustainability of civilization of the
species and i
strongly believe that comes from
localism and that's really what
uh what we're working towards and so you
know i would say
we spun up a company recently called
informal systems and you know i'm the
ceo of that company
we're heavily involved in in sort of um
the cosmos network
and building cosmos technology but our
mission is really verifiable distributed
systems
and organizations to support localism
right so having those sort of strong
guarantees we were talking about having
people understand the systems they're
using
what they get out of those systems not
these like you know 20 page legalese
terms and conditions that no one
understands but
um something that's really accessible to
humans and that it can empower
smaller and more local communities to
sort of take charge of their own
economic lives for sure uh before i let
you go i always ask everyone the same
three questions you get to ask me one at
the end
uh the first question is what's the most
important book that you've ever read
maybe three sure the original
consciousness and the breakdown of the
bicameral mind by dooley and james
uh the rainbow and the worm by maewan ho
and jitterbug perfume by tom robins
start with the first one why
um you know like i said the sort of four
questions that define my life
uh what does it mean to be human i think
this book does an incredible job of
outlining
human consciousness and where it came
from um
and how it relates to sort of history of
religion uh it's a
fascinating book on on consciousness
where it comes from
and uh you know what what it means to be
conscious today and
yeah and then uh second book
the rainbow and the worm the physics of
organisms is basically a tour de force
on how uh
magical and mysterious life is and and
what it means to be alive and she
may went home as a biochemist and she
really sort of cemented this idea for me
of uh biological organisms as sort of
the quintessential sustainable systems
and this idea
of you know building economic realities
and sort of more sustainable concentric
loops rather than like uh tornadoes and
so
she found out all kinds of amazing
things about the magic of organisms that
are just not easy to explain with
traditional sort of biomedical
understanding
um so anyone who's interested in sort of
the nature of life and you know what is
life i
highly recommend that book that's a
great one last one and the third yeah
tom robbins deer bug perfume
this is the book i wish i wrote it is a
sort of epic on the history of humanity
humanity and uh also the dangers of
um sort of arrogant technocratism right
and so that you know a lot of people
today are like oh we're gonna live
forever and you know they're pursuing
all this kind of stuff
um but you really need to not just think
about the brain but also the heart and
the rest of the body um and do things in
sort of a more holistic systemic manner
and so to just try to preserve
your mind because uh you know you're a
technocrat uh is really dangerous and he
does an incredible job in the story of
outlining that
um and sort of the right way to be
immortal let's say
very cool um the next question is all
about sleep
a little bit more personal what is your
sleep schedule and really this
question comes from our friends over at
eight sleep um
i'm uh investor in the business and uh i
used to sleep like six hours
now i sleep in the thermoregulated bed
it's amazing i sleep like eight nine
hours
uh i feel a completely different person
um and so now i may convert to the sleep
religion
are you somebody who sleeps a bunch do
you not sleep a lot which kind of your
sleep routine
how's that evolved over time oh it could
definitely be better
um nowadays i don't know i get to sleep
probably around midnight or so and i'm
up around eight so there's a
decent eight hours in there um but
sometimes it's more like six hours
um yeah i would love to start tracking
my sleep more i watch a lot of comedy
before i go to sleep to kind of clear my
mind
uh maybe that's not so great so i'm
trying to read a little bit more
um yeah i've been meaning to track my
sleep better so maybe this will finally
prompt me to do it
makes uh that makes sense to me uh last
question
aliens uh given your your earlier
questions that you spent much time
thinking about the answer here will be
pretty interesting uh aliens are you a
believer
or non-believer i am 100 a believer i
mean so on a number of fronts so first
of all the dolphins are conscious
in a very interesting way uh and so are
the cephalopods
um we actually run another company
called cephalopod equipment corporation
that is one of these proof of stake
validators
um so i have tremendous respect for the
cephalopods and the cetaceans the
dolphins and so on
um i also experimented a lot with
psychedelics and there is
something out there uh maybe it's just
like deep unconscious
psychological reality uh but this is a
world we do not begin to understand and
sort of you know physical reductionism
isn't going to cut it this universe is
also a universe that peoples
um you know life is not an accident it's
sort of an inevitability of the universe
we live in
it happened here on earth it definitely
happened in other places
but you know if we're right about how
old the universe is then
there's very likely life out there but
it may not be that much more advanced
than us
um and so it's sort of our duty i think
to to sustain ourselves and to achieve
sustainability
and not just blow ourselves up in sort
of a you know technocratic
kind of wet dream but uh but actually
like do this right um and if we're gonna
get to space you know
figure things out at home first and
that's why this sort of sustainability
stuff is so important to me
um and localism's a big part of that
thanks uh makes a lot of sense to me
what one question do you have for me to
finish up
um what is your favorite book
my favorite book uh i always answer the
same three which is kind of stupid uh
we're not stupid but just like
everyone's heard it before so uh
rich dad poor dad think and grow rich in
richmond in babylon i read them all when
i was 20 21 years old
you know pretty life-changing uh a book
that really made me
think um i'll give you two other books
that i read
uh in succession with each other and uh
and found very fascinating one was um
algorithms to live by
and the other was a book called super
forecasters
um and basically just this whole idea of
you know the crowd is usually right
um and also uh the ability to you know
essentially look at uh identify the
patterns
and the systems in your life and then
automate them use algorithm software et
cetera
i found both those books super
interesting too have you read
metaphors we live by no metaphors we
live by i have not yeah
i'm not sure if algorithms live by sort
of a play on that but metaphors we live
by was sort of the
um i think it was somewhat derivative of
the julian james book but sort of went
more in depth on how most of our like
conscious reality and understanding the
world is built out of metaphors
um and the authors even even wrote a
whole book on how all of mathematics can
be derived from the sort of metaphors of
our understanding growing up in a world
with gravity and so on which is a
fascinating kind of embodied approach to
cognition the thing i really wanted to
ask you was what is your favorite um
crypto or blockchain platform besides
bitcoin
bitcoin is so far ahead of everything um
i would say
i'll give you kind of a category that
i'm really interested in which is uh
um the decent like the market adopted
decentralized financial applications and
so what that means is like
you know i'm generally of the belief
that 95 of all of the things that are
being built right now will end up not
being valuable
uh that doesn't mean that we shouldn't
build them like actually in fact like
the experimentation and the
pursuit of innovation is important like
the journey is always more important
than the end result because the journey
leads to the end result
um but with that said i think there's
very very few uh
what i do have as kind of two core
thesis is digital assets will be more
valuable than
uh analog or electronic cusip assets i
think people kind of are wrapping their
head around that now
but the second thing is the
decentralized products will be bigger
than the centralized products and so
when you start to look at some of these
decentralized products
um maybe like a unit swap is a good
example right where
uh it's just doing you know 600 million
to a billion dollars in annualized
revenue
uh from trading fees on a decentralized
exchange like i don't care what your
tribalism is i don't care what your kind
of
religiousness is uh to any of these
ecosystems doesn't actually matter
what ecosystem that's being built and
it's just you can't argue against that
type of market adoption
um and so i think that stuff super
interesting and i'm spending a bunch of
time trying to wrap my head around it
and frankly just learn
right i don't even know necessarily if
i've got a ton of opinions about
individual things um it's more so just
me trying to really really learn about
you know why is the market adopting
certain things and kind of
where what does that highlight as to
what's next
cool where can we send people to uh to
find you on the internet or find more
about cosmos
the cosmos dot network uh for cosmos
informal dot systems for our company in
formal systems
and i am buckmanster buch m-a-n-s-t-e-r
on
twitter amazing listen thank you so much
for doing this ethan we're going to do
it again in the future
sounds great thanks a lot